hey 42 here dances and choreographers
have the highest divorce rates followed
by bartenders and massage therapists
welcome to RIF a 2003 survey showed that
1/3 of Americans believe their haggis
was a small animal the best-known
Western names in China are Jesus Christ
Richard Nixon and Elvis Presley a lion's
roar can be heard from five miles away
the crashing waves that we hear when we
place a seashell next to our ear is not
the ocean but rather the sound of blood
surging through the veins in our ear any
cup shaped object placed over the year
will produce the same effect children
grow faster in the spring time rubber
bands last longer when refrigerated a
shark is the only fish that can blink
with both eyes peanuts are one of the
ingredients of dynamite the longest one
syllable word in the English language is
screeched and finally Winston Churchill
was born in the ladies toilets during a
dance thanks for the view subscribe for
more thoughty2
you